falcons are in our dna they run in our
bloods
the falcons makes even a bond between me
and my my son they're part of what we
are
my name is hamdan ahmed mujeren
i'm a falconer i'm from dubai
the falcon is the icon of our country it
is even on our passport valkyrie is a
part of our heritage my grandfather and
grand grandfather used to hunt with it
[Music]
these days they make competition of
falcons it's basically like the drag
race it's a quarter mile 400 meter
you release their falcon from point a to
b
the fastest falcon cross this distance
is the winner
i had a bird last year that got 15
seconds this is the best time in factory
while you're training you have to learn
how to make this bird put the full
effort from your fist to the guy who's
calling it
chasing the plane or chasing the drone
it's a good exercise for the falcon
this is one technology which i think
took us to the next level of training
the falcon it is much easier much faster
because we can train
20 30 birds
in a row
we have hundreds of birds i love them
all yes but some of them they are
special their character is different
they're smart they're clever they're
aggressive
we train the birds every day morning and
evening non-stop there is no no resting
in it i feel proud of it
all in this sport of falconry from
through my father and my brothers
i remember the first falcon i got when i
was four years old i cannot forget this
day this is maybe the best day of my
life
i'm thinking could i pass it to my son
or not because this generation is
different with their ipad and other
stuff
but luckily i i managed to he loved it
by nature so i'm very happy he is
attached to it
[Music]
he started training real birds when he
was a little bit more than two years old
when i watch him at home he's basically
all of the time playing with a falcon
toy
the fact that my son does love this
hobby makes us proud all of us not only
me the whole family we're happy that our
children are still attached to this
hobby so
our heritage is still going through us
and through our children
[Music]
you